we fast forward man obviously right
before you getting ready to fight for
the title that whole incident with uh
with conor mcgregor happens you remember
that mike right which uh that made
headlines man
were refunded at that time when that
whole thing happened because the whole
story was i know it was it happened with
arts because artem was saying something
in russian
to you guys i don't know what he had
said but you ended up i don't know who's
i don't know if you slapped him or
whatever but that led conor mcgregor to
come
in obviously you know throw a dog
through the bus
i would think like a lot of friends come
today
when when i see a lot of people outside
i think wow
like friends come here like they want to
take pictures with someone you know it's
like uh
you know when you go to the when you go
to the
like likes real party i talk about party
like
fighting party you know yeah why you
bring camera with you
yeah you're going to worry you don't
need camera you know
this is a show like it was lara um
what's your name security security there
like lara but they
they try to just show you know when i go
to do something i slept oh i slept
all his team okay you know like when you
go to the war you have goal
you have to do something you have to
take your goal
when you take your goal you become
winner
they just come here to show up like you
know like
promote the fight like everything drama
it was it was like
we were going to weigh in and a lot of
media there
i don't understand a house like uh like
20 camera there no it's like a lot of
security
like like of course nobody gonna let you
fight
there this is 100 you know yeah damn i
know it was like that what
what's your take on that mikey what did
you take on mcgregor doing that
that's pretty drastic yeah too much
yeah the phone can get hurt real bad
yeah well two i think two people were
hospitalized uh
yesterday because the glass kind of went
in their eyes there's
a how many years is that yes and one
woman and rose
rose three and then the other dude uh
yeah ray boris yeah yeah
obviously you go out you beat ella
quinta for the title man
now now now you're the champion at the
light heavyweight division
and then that's pretty much actually
that was the start of of the mcgregor
fuel lightweight and i'm like
heavyweight
uh light yeah lightweight lightweight
and i said i have you with me now i look
like heavyweight
but i competition the lights but you
know it's like next day after this fight
i jumped to the training camp
really because i knew we're gonna fight
we're gonna fight and i
i just was waiting for contract date
just next day i beginning training i
don't stop
yeah because i know it's like when fight
fight time come you know it's like uh
someone someone have to show like spirit
heart you know
but when time come you know like i was
preparing so hard
when time come and inside the cage when
he said this to me is like
i was stuck with him like crazy and he
gave back to me like hey it's only
business and i was like
it sounds like you know like when when
my father go crazy with me
i tried to make him stop you know yeah
and i like try to
found some excuse hey you know like
it sounds like same same same thing you
know like
and i was what i was preparing for these
things
yeah you know i was like i was preparing
for war
and when i come here i don't fight
opponent you know
like this is make me empty and why i did
this after the fight why i jump
everything like
i don't think like people gonna
understand this because
like it was so emotional so you time for
me i can probably i can probably
elaborate there for you because the
first time i fought demetrius johnson
he knocked me out and and two minutes
and 36 seconds to the body
which is the worst my knees and i didn't
feel as a man
that i shook his hand that i gave him a
fair fight i think that ate me
for you you putting a beat down at
mcgregor did you feel the exact same
thing like he didn't give you the hand
like he should have
ah you know you know you know what i'm
saying it was a little bit different it
was a little bit different you know
like it wasn't like i was expecting more
yeah i was expecting more and
you know it's like when i go like i talk
with him he give me this executes oh
this is like just only business
everything like
okay when i catch his neck and i choke
him like
he hit up you know it's like and i think
hey you bring like
thousands people from ireland here on
different part of world
and you tap in front and like and you
talk about like about warrior or
something like this
how you can tap go sleep go sleep
like and he tapped and i was like okay
it's not enough i need something and i
was like
and i see like some his corners like
talk with me like
and i think oh i have to bite his heart
you know
and i jump to like you know like catch
something of course i know like a lot of
people
but nobody wanna talk with me i don't
understand everybody
everybody wanna talk with me in press
conference in twitter you know
inside the cage like damn here it goes
the ego
whoa so you went after you went after
dylan dennis right
is that how you're trying to hit or just
trying to hit somebody you're just still
playing
i just tried to bite his heart you know
yeah that time i thought
i really want to bite his heart you know
i don't under i don't know
maybe not like uncle mike dude
[Laughter]
everybody you guys are all everybody
wanted to get a piece of them why
because he disrespected your family
he disrespected your faith he
disrespects your father your mother i
mean
he disrespected everybody okay i have a
question
if there is no police what's going to
happen
you tell me there is no no no no no
referee
no police no referee kill him even
sacrifice live
remember you remember this fight mike
yeah
this is this is real things the real
thing is not with bus you know when
200 security around like camera
everything this is real thing
you know like i was like i would think i
was preparing for real world you know
when i come there i don't find nobody
you know this is make me like put me
like in emotional you know make me
emotional
because i don't find nothing yeah
i was expecting more you know did you
take a lot of uh
for for mike man you obviously you've
seen mike's face man mike you you've had
a couple rides back in the day in the
ring
remember that last uh the last holyfield
fight
can you talk about this a little bit
because first fight like he he
he hit you with the head i think like
couple times
what do you think about this do you ever
bite someone no no
no but i could i could feel the
frustration man like you know what i'm
saying
like you you understand his emotional
life yes yes
yeah but i've been head-butting man so i
know what that thing feels like it
pisses you off because there's some
people that are really sneaky with it
would you say mike
people that really have a hard head
really slide that thing in
what happened after now you guys cool
good yeah what happened was there
yeah it's gone
yeah crazy would you would you would you
think mike obviously
mike has made he has reconciled with
holyfield man
and obviously i saw the comments too
that uh that conor mcgregor uh
that conor mcgregor just recently said
about and i don't want to bring it up we
don't got to talk about it either could
be
because there's i think he's really
going overboard he's got to hit me with
that one too
so i'm down straight
but do you talk about you talking about
last tweet yeah the last tweet man
you know it's like to come inside my
mind you know
like like this is very hard to give me
people can say whatever they think you
know did you hear about that mike
what did you hear about the last tweet
mcgregor did with uh khabib
no yeah because khabib had mentioned and
i've if you don't mind me talking about
it yeah it's okay
yeah khabib had mentioned it's like it's
it's it's good over evil
when he was fighting porya when mcgregor
fought poirier
and he says uh good will always prevail
and then uh
you know conor connor's crazy ass he he
rose like yeah man it's good versus evil
and then he says something about
along the lines that kind of covet kind
of took your dad in that sense
like going below the belt you know what
i'm saying like completely
but something that i will say about that
your dad has always said that
at one time at one point he would invite
conor mcgregor
to a barbecue man no it's like my my dad
was
like different level you know about like
this situation he always like
his heart was like so like clean you
know
and uh you know it's like like when he
talked about this
uh you know only evil can talk about
your
father like wife kids religion
like if you normal like humanly you're
never gonna talk about this stuff you
know
like for me it's like so i think he
posts this tweet like uh
drunk too much or do something yeah
and the next day i think and he always
delayed his tweet and i think
when he become a normal life and he said
oh
what i did like and he delete this is my
opinion what he do like all the time
yeah how would you take that mic how
would you take that if uh
you know obviously we got to sell the
fight but there's a limit man there's a
hey man
you know hey listen um you can't be
talking about people's dads and
co-workers listening to perishing
i just know um in this business
everything goes you know everything goes
promoting the fight everything goes no i
agree
when you if you want to promote the
fight yeah but
uh you know it's like
when when someone is not with us you
know
he's not even alive i don't think this
is like this is show you what you have
inside
this is show your like how dirty you are
yeah like this is show like when you
come when you
when one of the best in the world and
you and you come and you
punch someone like 77 years like old
girl like
old man this is show your heart this is
show who you are inside
how dirty you are you know and you know
it's like uh
when you have parents and when you have
kids how you can
show yourself like this i don't
understand why his clothes people don't
tell him hey
what's going on yeah can i give you and
that's what i know from your perspective
obviously
there's something about mike that i will
say that he's you've reconciled with
everybody mike
yeah they're from lennox lewis no
because i'm not gonna let that stuff
kill me yeah having a girl you're not
liking somebody that takes a lot of
energy
i don't have the energy my kids
grandparents and wife
cousins that's too much people i love to
waste their energy on another waste of
no [ __ ] scumbag
yeah that's just not what i want to do a
couple years they would have got me on
that
i'd be in jail and [ __ ] not today
yeah so you heard what he said could be
mike doesn't hold grudges it's too much
for him to hold grudges are you are you
at that grudge
a stage with mcgregor it's okay man
we're all human dude it's okay to feel a
little animosity
towards somebody but do you think you'll
ever let it go uh
you know i think i think uh
i think like one of the
biggest reason why i become champion
i think this is about my mental part
how i can control my emotional you know
i
i think i can control anything anything
happen with me in the world i can
control this
i can handle this you know and i know
like a lot of people like i remember
when i when i was supposed to fight with
him like
like coach tell me hey you you have to
focus you know it's like
and i was like okay i'm focused you say
oh you call home you call friends i said
no i'm good
this is normal for me you suppose after
like 30 minutes
your biggest fight in your life biggest
fight in ufc history become
you call your friends on phone like i
said coach
please don't worry everything is good
i'm good i'm relaxed
and when time comes i'm gonna show you
you know what do you what do you think
what do you think conor mcgregor is
missing in his life
what do you think it is man
uh if you don't say there's if you had a
pinpoint one thing
when you become rich when you become
famous
uh some people they lose real
real people around him they lose them
because uh
because real people who love you they're
gonna tell you true
but fake people they always say oh
you're good you're good you're good you
know it's like
they never say not say to you nothing
because they don't want to upset you
because they know they're gonna lose
this comfortable zone
but but you know it's like but real
people they don't care about this
they was they was with you before you
become famous and rich
and they don't care about your money
they don't care about your fame
they just love you and they when they
say to you true
you don't like this because of your ego
you know and
i think he loses a lot of people around
him yeah it's just my opinion i don't
think he have
like people who was with him be before
when he become champion and uh everybody
needs someone
who remind you hey you're doing this
this is a bad
this is good this is bad this is life
like you don't need
yes man you don't need people that just
to just buy you obviously you've been
there mike
yeah what's your take on what he just
said mike i used to know how people are
man
they're like monkeys the height we get
them when we show our ass
say that again i think we like monkey
yeah the higher we get the more we show
our ass
it is it's true man it's really true
most of the people like this
i agree with them or most of the people
like this yes
no not everybody but most most most of
the people
[Music]
you